there's a comedic version of this
i don't know if you've seen this movie
it's called the death of stalin yeah
i i like that i wish it wasn't so
there's a movie called in glorious
bastards about
uh you know hitler and well you know so
on
for some reason those movies pissed me
off i know a lot of people love them
but like i just feel like uh there's not
enough good
movies even about hitler there's good
movies about the holocaust
but even hitler there's a movie called
downfall that people should watch i
think it's the last few days of hitler
that's a good movie
turned into a meme but it's good but on
stalin i
feel like i may be wrong on this but at
least in the english-speaking world
there's not good movies about the evil
of stalin
that's true let's try to see that i
actually so i i agree with you on the
glorious passage i didn't love the movie
um because i felt like kind of the
the stylizing of it right the whole like
tarantino kind of
um tarantinoism yeah if you will kind of
detracted from it and made it seem like
i'm serious a little bit um
but death of stalin i felt differently
maybe it's because of the comedy to
begin with so it's like i'm expecting
you know seriousness
but it kind of depicted
the absurdity of the whole situation in
a way right uh i mean it was funny so
maybe it does make light of it but it
it somebody grows probably like this
right like a bunch of kind of
people they're like oh [ __ ] right like
you're right
but like the thing is it was so
close to
like what probably was reality that was
caricaturing reality
to where i think an observer might think
that this is not
like they might think it's a comedy in
well in reality
this is that's the absurdity of uh
how people act with dictators i mean
that's
i guess it was too close to reality for
me
the kind of banality of like what were
eventually like fairly evil acts right
but like yeah they're they're just a
bunch of people trying to survive
and like because i think there's a good
i haven't watched yet the good movie on
uh the movie on churchill
um with uh gary oldman i think
is gary oldman i might be making that up
i think he won like he was nominated for
an oscar something
so i like i love these movies about
these humans and stalin
like chernobyl made me realize the the
hbo show that there's not enough movies
about russia
that capture that
spirit i'm sure it might be in in
russian there is
but the fact that some british dude that
like did
comedy i feel like he did like hang over
some [ __ ] like that
i don't know if you're familiar with the
person who created chernobyl but he was
just like some guy that doesn't know
anything about russia
and he just went in and just studied it
like did a good job of creating a
and then got it so accurate like
poetically
and uh the facts that you need to get
accurate he got accurate
just the spirit of it down to like the
bowls that pets use
just the whole feel of it it was nice it
was good yeah i saw this here
yeah it's it's incredible she made me
made me wish that somebody did a good
like um 1930s
uh like starvation that stalin led to
like leading up to world war ii
and in world war ii itself like
stalingrad and so on like
i feel like that story needs to be told
millions of people died it
and it's it's to me it's so much more
fascinating than hitler because
hitler is like a caricature of evil
almost
that it's so especially with the
holocaust
it's so difficult to imagine that
something like that
is possible ever again stalin to me
represents something that is possible
like the
the so interesting like the bureaucracy
of it
is so fascinating that it potentially
might be happening
in the world now like they were not
aware of like with north korea another
one that
like there should be a good film on and
like the possible things that could be
happening in china with overreach of
government
i don't know there's a lot of
possibilities there i suppose
yeah i i wonder how much you know i
guess the archives should be maybe more
open nowadays right i mean for a long
time they just
we didn't know right like or anyways no
one in the west knew for sure
well there's a i don't know if you know
there's a guy named stephen codkin
he is a historian of stalin that i spoke
to on this podcast i'll speak to him
again
the guy knows his [ __ ] on stalin
he like read everything and it's
cool it's so fascinating to
to to talk to somebody like he knows
stalin better than stalin
himself it's crazy like you have
seen i think he's a princeton he he is
basically his whole life is
stalin stalin yeah it's great and in
that context he also
talks about and writes about putin a
little bit
you